- Hi everyone,
Sal here with my three-year-old son Azad,
and we're excited to announce the launch of
Khan Academy Kids!
Which is designed to take students like Azad,
ages two to five, to become lifelong learners.
- [Reya] Hi friend, welcome to my room!
- [Sal] Kids love this program because it's really fun.
- [Peck] Awesome!
- [Sal] Friendly characters like our narrator Kodi Bear –
- [Kodi] Welcome to Khan Academy Kids!
– interact with them throughout the learning experience.
And we've combined tasks like math and reading
with activities like drawing and storytelling.
We really think parents and teachers
are going to love Khan Academy Kids
because it's aligned with important standards
like the Common Core
and the Head Start Learning Outcomes Framework.
There are thousands of activities
and original books in the program.
Khan Academy Kids also promotes
social emotional development
through topics like empathy and sharing.
And what's more, we've partnered with
Super Simple Songs,
Bellwether Media,
and National Geographic Young Explorer Magazine
to provide learning materials kids will love.
Khan Academy Kids is a free mobile app
available in the App Store,
and in beta for Google Play and Amazon.
Download today and let the joyful learning begin!
[Sal] Hi everyone, Sal here.
I'm here to announce–
[Azad] Blaaaaaah. [Giggles]
[Sal] Shh.
Hi everyone, I'm here with my son Azad,
who's three years old, to announce the launch of
Khan Academy Kids, which is designed
to get students aged two to five
ready to become learners for life.
- [Azad] Download today.
- [Sal] Yeah, say it loud and funny!
- [Azad] Download today!
- [Sal] Download today and let the joyful learning begin!
How do they do this in movies?